bonjour david vous êtes devant
l'assemblée nationale où la loi de
sécurité globale doit être
définitivement adopté aujourd'hui un
sentiment d'un devoir accompli pour les
députés et les sénateurs après de vives
polémiques un autour de cette
proposition de loi
et oui et magalie est en tout cas le
ressenti général après de longs mois de
tractations et de vives contestations
populaires dans la rue depuis novembre
dernier vous parliez de devoir accompli
le sénat estime avoir écouté le peuple
avoir écouté cette contestation
un texte riche je le rappelle de 70
articles principal point d'achoppement
le fameux article 24
le sénat à majorité de droite l'a
largement réécrit en créant dans le code
pénal un délit de provocation à
l'identification
il ne fait plus référence à la loi de
1881 sur la liberté de la presse c'est
ce qui était principalement reproché à
cette proposition de loi pour marc
philippe daubresse sénateurs les
républicains du nord et rapporteur du
texte cette version définitive du texte
qui sera sans surprise adopté
aujourd'hui au parlement
elle répond parfaitement aux inquiétudes
des réfractaires du texte écouter dans
la mesure où le compromis reprend 80 %
des propositions du sénat nous sommes
plutôt satisfaits
il y à un meilleur équilibre entre
liberté et sécurité les journalistes
peuvent filmer et diffuser ce qu'ils
veulent ce qui est interdit c'est de
donner des informations personnelles sur
un policier
par exemple avec l'intention de lui
nuire le cadre est clair et libertés
publiques respecté et le conseil
constitutionnel lorsqu'il sera saisi par
le premier ministre pour en attester
le conseil constitutionnel comme l'a dit
le sénateur sera la dernière étape avant
la promulgation officielle du texte la
gauche mais en tout cas a promis et jean
castex l'avait annoncé dès novembre lors
du premier examen au palais bourbon
oui malgré cette réécriture et cette
confiance affichée en tout cas par le
sénat
ça ne suffit pas à dégonfler la
contestation des vides
énoncer les revendications de la
coordination a contre le projet de loi
qui réunit syndicats de journalistes et
organisations de défense des libertés
sont toujours elles mêmes ils ont une
nouvelle fois réclamé le retrait de ce
texte l'article 24 n'est pas le seul
problème de cette proposition de loi
usage élargi des caméras piétons des
policiers des drones du port d'armes
pour les forces de l'ordre
hors service ou encore la création d'une
police municipale à paris de nombreuses
mesures continue d'être contestée
continue d'être débattue au sein de
l'hémicycle
pour rappel en première lecture de
plusieurs membres de la majorité
s'étaient abstenus et ce dernier volet
qu'on ne convainc toujours pas elle est
plus sceptique
à savoir qu'une conférence de presse
aura lieu à midi à proximité du palais
bourbon
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions david khalifa en direct de
l'assemblée nationale à paris